CALLING BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER SIX TO ORDER.
AND WE'RE GONNA ASK MISTER
OBERNOLTE TO PRESENT HIS --
FIRST TWO BILLS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
GUESS MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL PRESENT FIRST ON A CA
ELEVEN I'M SURE WE'RE ALL AWARE
OF THE GOOD WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
DOES IN ASSISTING THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR FISCALLY --
A FISCALLY IMPACTFUL BILLS A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THE
LA WHO IS -- SHARES A BUDGET
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE PROP ONE
FORTY WAS PASSED.
BY THE VOTERS.
THE LEGISLATURE WAS COME FORCED
TO COMPETE WITH RESOURCES WITH
THE LA ALL HIGH AT THAT TIME THE
STAFF OF THE LA -- WAS CUT BY
OVER 60% AND IT HAS NEVER BEEN
RESTORED. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
HOW DIRE THAT SITUATION HAS
BECOME THE ONLY -- CURRENTLY HAS
ABOUT THE SAME NUMBER OF
ANALYSTS AS THEY HAD BACK IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND TO GIVE
YOU SOME PERSPECTIVE ON THAT THE
SIZE OF THE STATE BUDGET.
HAS GROWN BY OVER FIFTY TIMES OR
OVER 5000% SINCE THEN AND ARE
CONSEQUENTLY THE NUMBER PROGRAMS
THAT REQUIRE OVERSIGHT HAS ALSO
GROWN SO.
WE WOULDLIKE TO SEE THE LA
YOU'LL BE ABLETO GET BACK TO
THE POINT.
WHERE THEY WERE BEFORE NINETEEN
NINETY IN PROP ONE FORTY WHERE
THEY WERE ACTUALLY DOING FISCAL
ANALYSIS OF THE MAJORITY OF THE
BILLS THAT WERE IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE?
THEY'RE MEANT TO BE THE COUNTER
WEIGHT FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND AS SUCH -- I THINK
THAT THEY NEED TO RESOURCES TO
DO THEIR JOB SO ACA.
ELEVEN WOULD AMEND THE STATE
CONSTITUTION TO MOVE THE LA --
OUT FROM UNDERNEATH THE CAP OF
PROP.
ONE FORTY BUT TO BE CLEAR --
NORMALLY I'M IN FAVOR OF SMALLER
GOVERNMENT BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE AGENCY THAT'S TASKED WITH
BEING THE WATCHED OGLE FOR STATE
SPENDING.
AND ADVISING THE LEGISLATURE ON
MAKING GOOD FISCAL DECISIONS --
THAT AGENCY I WANT TO HAVE ALL
OF THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO DO
THEIR JOB SO MUCH CHAIR LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR JOINT AUTHORED
THIS BILL WITH ME AND I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON A SCALE OF A
THANK YOU.
FINANCE HI GOOD AFTERNOON A
DOLLY EDITOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE -- BUT WOULD NOTE
THAT -- THAT THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT COULD RESULT IN FUTURE
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE LA L..
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WILL INCUR
ONE TIME COSTS TO PUT THIS
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I JUST A QUICK
QUESTION -- TO TOWARD VICE CHAIR --
BUT ROUGHLY.
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE ROUGH NUMBER
OF EMPLOYEES FOR FINANCE VERSES
THE ROUGH NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
FOR LAND DO YOU RECOLLECT -- OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD I DON'T KNOW
THE EXACT ANSWER BUT IT'S IT'S
MANY TIMES THE DEAL OF HAS MANY
TIMES MORE ANALYSTS THAN THE LA
OR DOES. FIVE FINANCED YOU HAVE
THE NUMBER OF A FINE IT'S WELL
WE WE HAVE THE NUMBERS ARE.
SO IS JUST JUST.
TO ONE FORTY EIGHT SO JUST A
STATE FOR THE RECORD --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS A FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT STAFF.
COMPARED TO FIFTY ONE STAFF AT
THE LA OFFICE.
SO SO EIGHT I GUESS THAT WOULD
ONLY TIME NOW ALMOST.
TEN TO ONE OKAY.
LET ME JUST SAY FIRST OF ALL I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR TAKING ON THIS ISSUE BRING
THIS A CA FORWARD -- I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ALIENS OFFICE GETS
BROUGHT BACK TO ITS -- PREVIOUS
STAFFING AND REALLY NOT ONLY DO
THEY PROVIDE IT -- VERY
IMPORTANT FISCAL ANALYSIS THEY
ALSO PROVIDE A VERY.
VERY STRONG AND IMPARTIAL POLICY
ANALYSIS ON ON MANY KEY -- LONG
TERM ISSUES I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY -- WE DON'T HAVE
THE FORESIGHT TO SAY TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THE WILDFIRE ISSUE
THAT WOULDHAVE BEEN AN ISSUE
WHERE WE REALLY COULD HAVE.
USED THEIR ASSISTANCE ARE REALLY
USE THEIR USER GUIDES BUT MANY
OF THESE OTHER ISSUES THEY PLAY
A VERY FOR CRITICAL ALSO THANK
YOU -- FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
TO LIGHT AND AND REALLY CHAMPING
THIS -- WHY DON'T WE SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET ONE WE
MOVE ON TO THE A. B.?
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- SO WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE FISCALE SYSTEM AND
ITS IMPORTANCE IN BRINGING STATE
FINANCES INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
BUT I THINK EVERYONE IS ALSO
HEARD ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE HAD IN DEPLOYING FISCALE --
JUST WITHIN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS STATE COMPTROLLER BETTY
ISSUED A LETTER TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN WHICH SHE
EXPRESSED GRAVE CONCERN.
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY
USING FISCALE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE HER WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT SHE NEEDS. TO
COMPILE THE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT AT THE END OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR AND THE CONSEQUENCE OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO COMPILE THAT
REPORT OR BY HAVING TO ADMIT
THAT WE HAVE -- WE HAVE --
ESTIMATES IN THERE INSTEAD OF
ACTUAL FIGURES.
MIGHT BE SOMETHING AS SEVERE AS
GETTING A DOWNGRADE TO THE
STATE'S DEBT RATING SO IT'S IT'S
A VERY DIRE SITUATION THERE.
LAST YEAR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR WAS ASKED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FISCAL SYSTEM AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION AND DEPLOYMENT
AND THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE ISSUED
A SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL REPORTING.
FROM HIS CAL SO THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF
FISCAL TO INCLUDE THE ITEMS
IDENTIFIED BY THE AUDITOR IN
THEIR ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL AND AT THE
PROPER TIME WOULD REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR ON THIS WAS THE OTHER ****
ALL GO BACK TO WILL GO TO
FINANCE.
FOR HI YES WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION YET ON THIS
BILL BUT WE WOULD CONCUR WITH
THE STAFF'S ANALYSIS.
OF MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU -- TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION HAS BEEN VERY
CRITICAL.
TO ALL THE AGENCIES AND
FORCEFULLY HASN'T GONE NEARLY AS
SMOOTHLY AS AS WE'D LIKE IT'S A
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU -- FOR FOR
BRING IN THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD AS WELL.
OKAY.
SO -- WILL BE AGAIN MOVING THESE
BILLS FORWARD TODAY.
WITH THE INTENTION OF TAKING
ACTION IN FULL COMMITTEE ON
APRIL TWENTY NINTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CRUSHER.
WITH THAT WE HAVE TO OTHER
AUTHORS WE ARE WAITING
[inaudible]
FOR YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
MR REALLY COME ON UP.
YOU'RE THE NEXT CONTESTANT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER SIX
THANK YOU AB.
THREE TWO THREE THIS IS A FAIRLY.
STRAIGHTFORWARD REQUEST HERE
BECAUSE OUR STATE S FACING A
NEW NORMAL FOR NATURAL DISASTERS.
THIS THREATENS TO STRAIN OUR
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS ACCOUNT.
WHICH WILL ASSIST ALL OF US IN
PREPARING FOR ANY FUTURE
REDUCTION OR STAGNATION IN THE
STATE'S REVENUES.
IN THE EVENT OF A NATURAL
DISASTER CASH FLOW WILL BE
CRITICAL TO COVER THE COST OF
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS.
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE WILL BE
NECESSARY NOT ONLY TO ADDRESS
SERIOUS PUBLIC AN ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS BUT TO
FACILITATE A QUICK RECOVERY.
LAST YEAR'S FIRES ARE EXPECTED
TO EXCEED THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN DISASTER ASSISTANCE COSTS.
WELL FEDERAL ASSISTANCE IS
COMMON IN THE AFTERMATH OF
DISASTERS THE TIMING AND AMOUNT
THE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS CAN
OFTEN BE UNCERTAIN.
IN SUMMARY THIS PROPOSAL WORK
RATE.
A RESERVE ACCOUNT SO CALIFORNIA
CAN SAVE MONEY DURING BUDGET
SURPLUS YEARS AND REMAIN
PREPARED TO FRONT ANY NECESSARY
RECOVERY COSTS.
WITHOUT HAVING TO WAIT FOR
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS.
AGAIN TIME WILL BE OF THE
ESSENCE.
IF IF UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE
IN FUTURE NATURAL DISASTERS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
YOU MISTER DAILY -- FINANCE WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL WE'RE STILL ABOUT
EVALUATING THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS
AND LOOK FOR TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS IS THAT MOST OF FOR
BUDGET.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR ABROAD.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD -- IN THE PAST I
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
CREATION OF ADDITIONAL RESERVE
ACCOUNTS JUST BECAUSE OF THE
WORDING OF STATE LAW WITH
RESPECT TO THE SPECIAL FROM --
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES THE
SFU THE SAYS WHEN THE SFU
BALANCE GET SUFFICIENTLY HIGH.
THAT THAT TRIGGERS AN AUTOMATIC
QUARTER PERCENT REDUCTION IN THE
STATE WIDE SALES TAX AND SO I
FELT THAT SOME OF THE EFFORTS IN
THE PAST TO CREATE.
THESE ADDITIONAL RESERVE
ACCOUNTS -- WERE DELAYING THE
DID THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
SALES TAX REDUCTION.
HOWEVER I DON'T HAVE THAT
THOUGHT ABOUT THE THE BILL THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING FORWARD HERE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE -- I I THINK
THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR BECAUSE OF
THE SPORADIC NATURE OF THESE
NATURAL DISASTERS AND THE
MAGNITUDE OF THEM AND THE TIMING
DIFFICULTIES WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT RESERVE ACCOUNT
WOULD BE A VERY GOOD THING.
SO I WANNA THANK YOU FOR BRING
THE BILL FORWARD -- DEFINITELY
GONNA BE GOOD FOR OUR STATE
BUDGET AND GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE JUST
SAID AND I RESPECT TO YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT.
THE PREVIOUS ADDITIONAL RESERVE%
THAT I HAD REQUESTED LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I DID JUST WHAT THEY AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL WE THINK IT'S
MUCH NEEDED UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE GOTTEN INTO THE DISASTER
BUSINESS YEAH -- AND IT'S ALL
TOO USED TO BE THE DISASTERS
WHAT HAPPENED ON OCCASION AND WE
RESPOND UNFORTUNATELY.
IT LOOKS TO BE THIS GOING TO BE
MORE OF AN ANNUAL OCCURRENCES SO
IT'S GOOD.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME MORE
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT MISTER CHAIR AND
I SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED I HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF CO AUTHORS
AS WELL -- BECAUSE OF THE
SCHEDULES TODAY WAS HARD FOR ANY
OF THEM TO ATTEND BUT I THINK
THEY'RE SIX OR SEVEN CO AUTHORS
GREAT THANK FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
SO WE'RE GOING TO STOP FOR A
SECOND AND TAKE ROLE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM.
TANK HERE BLOOM BRO.
COOPER.
FONG MCCARTY OBERNOLTE WEBER.
GREAT THANK YOU WE ARE WAITING.
FOR ONE MORE AUTHORED 2% AND
THEN WILL BE GOING TO OUR ON
OVERSIGHT HEARING WHICH WE HAVE
WITH ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION.
IN THE ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE
[inaudible] SIX CHAU
[inaudible]
UHHUH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I HAVE.
OKAY WELL THAT'S GOOD AWAITING.
THIS IS DAN.
YEAH YEAH YEAH -- EDITORS BUT
WITH ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION AND
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SHE WE YEAH.
MISS RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN
THROUGH THE RESCUE RIGHT YES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN
HERE TODAY.
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF AS
TODAY'S I SUBJECT MATTER HEARING.
DURING MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE I HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE.
OF SERVING ON BUDGET SUB.
ONE RELATING TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
THROUGH THESE HEARINGS ALONG%
WITH MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES I
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO DELIVER
SERVICES IN A RESPONSIVE MANNER.
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
D. H. C. S. HAS A TOTAL BUDGET
PROJECTION PROJECTED TO BE JUST
ABOVE A HUNDRED BILLION. FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY INCLUDING ALL STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS GIVING.
DH CS THE LARGEST DEPARTMENT
BUDGET IN THE STATE.
IN RECENT YEARS THE SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY OF THE H. YES.
HAS RESULT IN IT THE RESULT IN A
SIZEABLE.
BUDGET ERROR DUE TO POOR
INTERNAL PROCEDURES. FOR EXAMPLE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE MEDICAL
ESTIMATE WAS FOUND TO BE OFF BY
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION.
ME SAY THAT AGAIN ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS DUE TO A
MISCALCULATION OF COST AN
INCORRECT ACCOUNTING FOR
RETRACTED FEDERAL DRUG REBATE
PAYMENTS.
WHEN I ASKED -- FOR THE REASON.
THEY ATTRIBUTED THAT TO A
CLERICAL ERROR.
AND I THEN ASKED -- WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE MONEY AND THE
MONEY WAS SPENT ANYWAY EVEN
THOUGH THERE WAS A CLERICAL
ERROR?
THOSE TWO AREAS WERE SO LARGE
THEY LET IT LET THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO PROPOSE OFFSETTING
CUTS. TO LEGISLATIVE SPENDING
PRIORITIES TO PAY FOR THE LAST
FUNDING.
IN ADDITION TO THIS MATH OF
ERROR DATE CASF HAS CONTINUALLY
MISMANAGED SOME OF ITS SMALLER
OPERATIONS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THI OCCURRED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S HANDLING
OF ITS SUICIDE PREVENTION
HOTLINES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES IN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO DATE DATE CS IN ORDER
TO OPERATE THESE HOT LINES.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
APPROPRIATED ANOTHER FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION.
HOWEVER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DURING A SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING WE
WERE INFORMED THAT DESPITE THE
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING DTS WAS NOT
OPERATING A SUICIDE PREVENTION
HOTLINE AT ALL.
ON TOP OF THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WAS ASKING FOR ANOTHER FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION.
AFTER A LOT OF A LOT BACK AND
FORTH AND LETTERS.
AND LETTERS IT WAS FINALLY
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION THAT
THE HOT LINES WERE BEING HELD
DUE TO CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS.
THIS TROUBLING MISMANAGEMENT HAS
STUCK WITH ME BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVES
HERE.
WE DON'T BUILD CARS LEAVE US
THESE MONIES GO DIRECTLY TO HELP
PEOPLE AND THAT WAS A BIG
FRUSTRATION FOR ME.
THIS ISN'T THE DMV WHERE ERRORS
AND MISMANAGEMENT RESULT IN
INCREASED WAIT WAIT TIMES THIS
IS.
LITERALLY SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT WHERE
MISMANAGEMENT LEAVES PEOPLE'S
HEALTH AND LIVES AT STAKE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A HIGHER
STANDARD.
FROM THE TOP ON DOWN IT IS CLEAR
TO ME THAT DH CS NEEDS A CULTURE
CHANGE AND AN INCREASED FOCUS ON
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY SERVICE
AND RESULTS TO CALIFORNIANS.
I HOPE THE MY BILL AB SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN WHICH I'M -- I AM HERE
TO DISCUSS TODAY WILL BEGIN A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION ON HOW TO
BEST IMPROVE THE ACS AND
INCREASED PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO
PRESENT HERE TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO PRESENTING DISPEL IN
FRONT OF THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS RUBIO
FINANCE YES WE CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL -- BUT WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE ESTIMATED COST OF
SHIFTING TO PERFORMANCE BASED
BUDGETING A IS STILL TO BE
DETERMINED AND WILL DEPEND ON
THE STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGY.
A AND IS ALSO NOTED IN YOUR
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
WE ANTICIPATE THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES A GIVEN THE WORKLOAD
TO IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
INCLUDES THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN TWENTY
FIVE PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS FOR BUDGETING AND
ACCOUNTING TO STRENGTHEN THE
FISCAL FORCE CAN FOR FISCAL
FORECASTING.
OF THE MEDI CAL ESTIMATES AND TO
IMPROVE THE OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING OF CASH FLOW THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS MR MODE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY WOMAN PURPOSE
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING IS
AN INTRIGUING CONCEPT.
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN TRIED
BEFORE IN CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT NOT RECENTLY THOUGH.
BUT CHAIRMAN TING AND I OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO SPEARHEAD AN EFFORT.
TO TRY TO GET THE STATE TO TRY
ALTERNATIVE BUDGETING PRACTICES
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN TRYING -- TO
THE PILOT PROGRAM ON MISSION
BASED BUDGETING OR WHAT PEOPLE
CALL ZERO BASED BUDGETING SO THE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WE DOWN.
SHIFTING TO A ZERO BASED
BUDGETING FOR VARIOUS STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE DH CS IS AND THAT SCHEDULE
BUT I'M WONDERING WHY.
ARE WE WOULD INSTITUTE A NEW
KIND OF BUDGETING JUST FOR THIS
ONE DEPARTMENT WHEN WE ALREADY
HAVE THIS PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
TRANSITIONING TO WHY NOT JUST --
ARGUE FOR ACCELERATING AT A
TRANSITION TO ZERO BASED
BUDGETING FOR DHS.
UP WHAT THE PURPOSE THE FOR MY
BRING THIS BILL UP AND I DO
UNDERSTAND I WAS TOLD BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS.
BILL HAS BEEN PROPOSED AT LEAST
THREE TIMES BEFORE AND SO
INSTEAD OF DOING THE WHOLE STATE
BUDGET OBVIOUSLY AS A BIG
MONSTER -- MY FRUSTRATION WITH
DH CS HAS BEEN -- SO CONSISTENT
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WHERE
I'VE BEEN -- ASKING QUESTIONS
AND ASKING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY TO
HEAR.
SORRY -- THE END UP FOR EXAMPLE
THE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR OF CLERICAL ERROR THAT'S
WHAT I WAS TOLD IT WAS A
CLERICAL ERROR.
AND I SAID WELL IF IT WAS A
CLERICAL ERROR WAS THE MONEY.
AND THEY HAD SPENT THE MONEY AND
THEN -- WHEN I ASKED OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH?
FOR THEY DID ADMITTED AT FIRST
BITE I AFTER I PUSHED I SAID WHO
WAS HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
CHEMICAL -- AND THE ANSWER WAS.
NOBODY.
SAID WELL WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS NOBODY'S SOUL SO FOR ME --
AND SAID TACKLING THE WHOLE
ENTIRE BUDGET LIKE YOU ARE
PROPOSING D. EIGHT C. S. IS SUCH
A CRITICAL PROGRAM.
WHERE PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT
STAKE AND I THINK THAT'S WHY I
DECIDED TO DO IT HERE AND IN THE
AISLE COORDINATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT WE TALKED
ABOUT POSSIBLE WAYS OF DOING
THIS BY?
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
IT'S MISMANAGED DEPARTMENT.
AND FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS I'VE
BEEN FRUSTRATED FOR WITH
QUESTIONS AND LACK OF ANSWERS
EVEN THE SUICIDE PREVENTION LINE
IN COMMITTEE.
I WHEN I ASKED HAVE YOU GIVEN
THE THE THE MONEY FOR THE FOR
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION LINE I
WAS TOLD THREE TIMES YES YES YES
AND WHEN I LOOKED OVER TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THEY SAID WE HAVEN'T AS TO WHERE
THE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HEAD
JUMPED UP AND SAID ALL SORRY I
MISSPOKE.
AND TO WEAR WHICH I RESPONDED
WHY YOU'RE MISS SPEAKING PEOPLE
ARE DYING SOUL IN PARTICULAR
THIS DEPARTMENT.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND WE'RE LOSING LITERALLY
LOSING PEOPLE'S LIVES BECAUSE WE
ARE THEY ARE INEFFECTIVE AND SO
THANK YOU FOR FOR THE WORK FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE I I AGAIN I TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A BIG
BIG TASK -- BUT FOR ME IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE GET THIS
STARTED RIGHT AWAY I RESTART
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
IT.
IN LIEU OF BE YOU KNOW THE
PROCESS THAT YOU'RE DOING AGAIN
MAINLY BECAUSE IT'S PEOPLE'S
LIVES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
IS NOT THE DMV AGAIN.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
DIRECTLY AFFECTING PEOPLE ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I MEAN GIVEN THE FACT
THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THIS COMMITTEE ALREADY HAS A
PROCESS FOR TRANSITIONING
DEPARTMENTS TO MISSION BASED
BUDGETING.
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING BUT
KIND OF SIMILAR IN THE SENSE
THAT YOU TAKE A HOLISTIC LOOK AT
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO DO
WITH THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE TO
DO IT.
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING WHILE
WHAT THEY'RE NOT DOING WELL
WOULDN'T THAT SOLVE THE PROBLEM
IF WE JUST ACCELERATED THE
PROCESS OF APPLYING THE EXISTING.
ZERO BASED BUDGETING PROGRAM TO
DH YES I WOULD HOPE -- AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW UP TO TO THE
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW INTO TO
MISTER TING TO TO LET ME KNOW
WHERE WE FALL IN THIS PROCESS BY
I BE OPEN.
TO A CONVERSATION BUT AGAIN FOR
ME IT WAS A CRITICAL ASPECT OF
THE WORK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL IN -- HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THANK YOU IS THIS IF I
MAY THE ARM -- DEPARTMENT FIND
IT IS COMING BACK AND ARE ABLE
TWENTY NINE FULL HEARING.
IN THIS IS ROOM BECAUSE THEY'RE
IN THE BILL SO I THINK MY PRIOR
TO THAT I THINK WE CAN WE CAN
WORK TERM MERGE EVERYONE'S
EFFORTS SUCKS I THINK WE'RE ALL
TRYING.
TO MOVE IN THE SAME DIRECTION
AND I THINK THIS THIS DEPARTMENT --
IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT DEFINITELY
NEEDS TO BE -- NEED THIS AND
THAT THE PLAN NEEDS GREATER
OVERSIGHT I WE FOR UNFORTUNATELY --
NOT HAD.
AN EXPERIENCE WHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN COMPLETELY FORTHRIGHT IN
COMMITTEE RIGHT SO I THINK -- I
THINK WE'RE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND WENT ON
THIS RUBIO SAYING I THINK WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH BOTH GOALS.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND AND AS LONG AS I THINK THAT
WE'RE WORKING ALL TOWARD THE
SAME GOAL -- AGAIN IT'S
FRUSTRATING I YOU KNOW WE COME
FROM THE REAL WORLD WHERE WHERE
WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT FOR
THE ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE YOU
KNOW WHEN I I TALKED ABOUT THE
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION NOBODY
HAD AN ANSWER AND WHEN I ASKED
WAS HELD ACCOUNTABLE IT WAS LIKE.
NOBODY NOBODY'S BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND AT MINIMUM YOU
KNOW THE ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE IS
NOT HAPPENING SO I APPRECIATE
YOU YOU KNOW -- LISTENING TO TO
THIS REQUEST AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER I
THINK THAT IF WE CAN ESTABLISH
SOME KIND OF A BASELINE FOR SOME
OF THESE DEPARTMENTS WE THE
OUTCOMES WOULD BE BETTER AND I
FEEL LIKE SOMETIMES WERE
THROWING MONEY AT ISSUES THAT IF
WE DID.
BETTER BUDGETING ARE BETTER
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH MORE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT A MAYBE
BY STATE MAY NOT BE SO ROSY FOR
FOR ALL OF US IN THE FIRST FIRST
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE CRACKED.
ARE USUALLY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU SO
AGAIN WILL BE TAKING UP -- ALL
FOR BILLS IN OUR FULL COMMITTEE
ON APRIL TWENTY NINTH THANK YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
THERE THANK YOU AND I AGAIN I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE I WANT TO
JUST.
WE EMPHASIZE THAT THE WORK THAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT HAS
DONE BECAUSE I KNOW THIS WAS AN
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
UP IN MULTIPLE TIMES AND HE WAS
WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH US AND
TALK.
THROUGH HOW WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ON THIS VERY